[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
how Voldemort was able to get his body
back after its destruction as we moved
through the course of the films and
books we see Voldemort's physical form
transition from something requiring a
host as we've seen with his possession
of Quirrell in the first film to some
semblance of an independent physical
form in the fourth he basically goes
from ghost-like wisp to creepy baby that
Wormtail has to carry around and while
his body was weak it was a body
nonetheless even capable of wielding a
wand and casting a few spells so how did
he get it back the answer to this
question is actually a lot simpler than
you may have thought as Voldemort's new
physical form can be attributed to the
use of the rudimentary body potion a
potion that was actually invented by
Voldemort himself the rudimentary body
potion was created from two ingredients
unicorns blood and the Ginny's venom
Wormtail was able to source both
ingredients and produce this potion for
the Dark Lord under his instruction the
potion though effective at providing
Voldemort with a physical form was not
powerful enough to restore him to his
former glory which meant that he did not
have the level of power that he was
previously accustomed to so while the
body was not much it was still a body
and he knew that it would serve him well
until he was able to garner the
ingredients for a true return the true
return of Voldemort occurred when he was
given the regeneration potion a potion
that helps to restore noncorporeal
wizards to their bodies it is an old
piece of dark magic that required three
things bone of father flesh of servant
and blood of foe
to create this potion Wormtail and Barty
Crouch jr. helped Voldemort sauces
ingredients they were able to use worm
tails flesh for the warts father's bone
and harry's blood all of the ingredients
were then placed inside of cauldron and
Voldemort's rudimentary form was placed
inside what's interesting is that the
use of Harry's blood in this potion
ended up being one of the contributing
factors towards his downfall
the original potion involved with
returning Voldemort to his rudimentary
form is actually discussed by Voldemort
himself on chapter 33 page 569 of the
Goblet of Fire
Voldemort smiled his terrible smile his
red eyes blank and pitiless worm tells
body of course was ill adapted for
possession as all assumed him dead and
would attract far too much attention if
seen however he was the able-bodied
servant I needed and poor wizard though
he is Wormtail was able to follow the
instructions I gave him which would
return me to a rudimentary weak body of
my own a body I'll be able to inhabit
while awaiting the essential ingredients
for true rebirth a spell or two of my
own invention a little help from my dear
Nagini Voldemort's red eyes fell upon
the continually circling snake a potion
concocted from unicorn blood in the
snake venom Nagini provided I was soon
returned to an almost human form and
strong enough to travel
and that concludes a video it's a short
but sweet answer to this question and if
you guys have any further questions on
this topic please comment them down
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]